Hiiiiii
can you hear us hello hello oh the refunds can hear us okay I'm clear on the
refunds refunds are giving me a thumbs up can that I think that I can hear us
yeah right shall we introduce ourselves so we will introduce ourselves a miss
Moe would you like to go first please introduce yourself oh yes yes yes okay
okay hello my name is Miss Marisa I'm from VNU Gen 4 I am a demonist I like
drinking beer going fishing grilling and reaching out video games hello hello nice
to meet you I love drinking beer actually I love drinking alcohol oh my god okay
I'm sorry me and you both acti would you like to introduce yourself oh yeah um
hi everybody my name is Acti Matatovi I am a mad scientist Nikomata I don't know
why they say I'm mad I'm pretty cute actually but from rickery production gen 1
mid-fit I'm pretty cool oh yeah and a cook tuber and a cook tuber I keep I keep
forgetting but I think I forgot to say hi yeah hi me I'm I'm me I'm your
virtual plague doctor it's nice to meet you then I'm strongy calls I'm the
Scottish one from veiler thank you thank you I'll be here all week thank you
that's all I got the Scottish one that's all you're getting at me right so
today we are gathered here in this hallowed scary background of this
video game we're playing chained together now only one of us has had
previous experience with it before so I have no idea how this is gonna go but
we're just gonna hit play we're gonna see what happens and we're gonna pray to
the gaming overlords that we do not lag out at any point because we are scattered
across the globe for this connection right now okay oh there we go yeah I
can't remember what it is to pull but you can pull people if you need to oh yeah
it is above the head right so this is us in game check the fits what do you think
about the fit yeah quite a colorful bunch I mean we're at hell and we're
trying to climb out of it oh yeah oh this is your territory this isn't this is
literally my home yeah oh shit is that scared of me look up I know that guy yeah
wait you know the game what's this voice from that guy what's his name that's
Timothy yes wait what from what
wait whoa whoa whoa help I don't know I'm missing something I'm I'm a demon we're in
hell right now all right oh dumb I'm sorry sorry I thought you were like I
genuinely know the VA that we're listening to I was like oh what other stuff
the angel wings oh oh one out of ten wings found collect 10 oh so many could fly
maybe that would be the game so easy though I don't know cuz that you would fly
but you got like wait all people got flying cuz if all people are flying yeah but
if one person can just fly up oh my god do not look up that's what we have to
do it's fine you'll be right yeah we gotta go we're going up a little bit so I
seem if one of us falls off we can pull them back up again yeah yeah that's why
I am super strong do we go left or right I really go right look safe like there's a
bridge okay go oh that's left that's left this is right this year right put your
fingers out and then wait who's the front wait wait act is at the front I'm at I'm
the front no I'm the front I don't know yeah right we're going to the right oh shit fuck
oh no okay okay follow the leader leader leader follow the leader that's the big guy in the
background yeah okay does he have a name or is that Timothy
you look like shaggy from Scooby-Doo
sorry I'm getting too excited hold on Amy can you pull me up darling thank you
absolutely right okay you need to come to the edge to give me max change on yeah
right you ready oh well that confused me not gonna lie I don't know how I managed that
we made it to the sword that's my closet you look like you talk shit we're gonna go up
the chain yeah I'm gently I'm aging this chain so much right now I'm not falling off
this because that would be embarrassing this guy's got some cheeks on him
oh no the lava split right down his crack it's taking a knee for something I used
to be a little booty are you ready yeah okay let's try that again surely we're
gonna finish this game get it surely copium absolutely copium at least to a
very nice checkpoint would be nice I want to finish this casually I mean is
this by the same creators of just getting over it it's given just getting
over it take gameplay how long is this change oh my oh there we go there we go
don't worry shaggy's back where are you we actually came back from that it's quite
it's quite game a little closer guys walk a little closer okay I'm just double you I'm
repeatedly repeatedly hitting double you're shuffling I see the gliding if anything
oh we're almost there we're at the end of the chain right don't mess up now
I'm so gentle and nice thank you for being gentle with us yeah I don't know okay we're
better yeah I don't know where the checkpoints are actually not being we
don't need checkpoint don't look down where we do that was a mistake I'm not
doing that again do you get like terrified of heights and even in video
games I get ton of vision in video games we're like I feel like I'm in it like
when I get really panicky I think I'm actually in the game like that's why I
can't really play horror games because it freaks me out yeah no me too me too like I
can't differentiate that it's just if it's just a no real oh my god is this um
that why I wish you that's not it won't kill us but we'll fly off if we hit it
and we would have to go all the way back to the start is there no we have to jump
it like jump over at the same time at the same time yeah yeah wait wait wait it's
trying to go a little bit more to the right okay who's counting down I don't
know how to count I don't know who's good right on goal yeah yeah okay three two
one go oh my god we're doing it right we're ready we're crazy three two one
go okay okay okay okay very nice three wait wait there's spikes where oh oh yeah
I'm fine okay ready three two one go oh yeah oh yeah yeah yeah well spikes are
only hit us if we hit the wall wait oh no does it mean oh no does it do anything if we're here can we
no we need to come back from the elevator oh that's fine guys we we have a goal of no
whoa whoa whoa no fall damage is crazy yeah we're already in technically dead yeah this is
our punishment for all the bad deeds we've done is right everyone confess your
Vtuber sins oh please your sins that why are you in heck right now
oh he wants to go first extreme son accidentally flash some of the people I
have collabed with before we'll answer that that is a very very terrible sin you will
repent and we will get the heck out here this is why you're acting what is your
Vtuber sin my Vtuber sin that I just quit the game right now accidentally uh yeah that is
your sin that is your game right now how did you manage it was it did it shut down
because because I'm lagging so I was trying to set the FPS down and I wanted to press
like okay but it said the game and I pressed quit and I'm just not reading actually um
I mean that's a Vtuber sin you're not reading
nay okay so we're just losing progress I saved the game yeah is that really a Vtuber sin then
I mean I don't think so I mean will you get a pick let's find out let's find out if you'll get out
okay yeah I mean what's your Vtuber sin I play some games okay real I'm sure um
I see that I'm playing oh my gosh I'm doing team dark next I'm really excited oh my god you're
gonna do 100 completion uh maybe not a hundred percent but I'll get the emerald so I can finish
like the story of it oh my god that's so good um my Vtuber sin is I picked my gen mate selfishly
because I love them and I want the best for them so is that a sin though well I don't think that's
this man all right okay maybe that that's like quiet redemption if anything like a holy thing
okay okay my sin I admit it's a flashing someone bro come on well I mean maybe like you're overworking
yourself maybe miss ma and myself aren't too far apart because I may or may not have shared very
unique photos with my gen mates
what you're saying the the fucking the fucking the fucking red guy is talking way too
fucking low what you say oh you got the devil guy on you yeah I had the devil guy I'll be
maybe because she reconnected oh maybe because I because yeah I didn't hear what she said just
because I was saying my sin is maybe not so different from miss ma we are maybe from the same
book because uh I I may have shown myself to my gen mate so if the discord ever gets leaked
oh no we're all in a lot of trouble because we were all like oh here's what I look like here's
what I look like and I was like well the only fault was the half of myself really are mine with my
butt so I sit in the pictures of my butt and we were like we only knew each other for like two
weeks at this point that's very comfortable that's very comfortable yeah I talked to my
gen mates immediately yeah basically yeah like Sean's face and all that um so uh yeah that's my
sin my my sin is lust it's lust that's what my sin is oh okay okay you know oh like one of the seven
deadly I know I'm stuck I I can't remember all the seven is it like I know gluttony's one which is
yeah it's the only example
surely we're not gonna I don't know if I really have a sin though I just started like three weeks
ago three you're so innocent you're so new I I am a newborn I mean this one time I had
like come on my stream but I don't count this as a sin no what on your stream
huh what did you have on your stream
what potato pump oh you need hash browns okay oh hash brown you gotta squeeze the hash brown
it look really so are you ready this there's this time I don't want to touch it so I'm just
okay yeah yeah okay three two one go oh we're just MLG we're just MLG okay yep yep three two one go
okay this is where it fell last time okay three two one go
oh nice nice prompt three two one go oh we did it we're actually focused one at a time one at a
time yeah just gently in between right don't go down the chains don't get tangled yeah okay that
bridge is kind of just it's a broken bridge from shrek after the rescue princess Fiona
oh watch that recently yeah yeah oh my god we're spiders yeah and now a spider man oh my god
super mario sunshine oh my god okay I can see that I can see that yeah it's in the one like
squid map wait how do we or like in mario bros when you got the sweet like take the thing
like that's the little mushroom house there's like a mini thing guys we're just literally go to
all right so this is a trampoline I thought it was a black boy do we all go on it at the same time
um
I think so actually let's no let's sacrifice johnny go all right it was nice no news oh no
okay I'm pulling I'm pulling right okay pull no way we made that I thought that was over I
thought that was over once I went in the stratosphere I'm pulling I'm pulling I don't know why I couldn't
are you ready are you ready okay three two one go oh no they're okay oh my god oh my god okay
we're good we're good we're good we're good okay right three two one go oh my god how did we do
that was so good that was very clean that was easy peasy lemon squeaky hello master cave we only have
one fail I can't believe you've done this
you're already in the cult no only
okay I feel like it's quite nice to give us a ladder instead of making us like climb the rock
oh okay the bone that's so skinny oh um is there a tactic to this one um
just go for it but you gotta look I'm shuffling yeah I'm shuffling oh you got a look ahead
yeah all right hold on baby I'm just I'm doing the path and right now it looks like if we take the
no which way to go okay we can go right we take a little left but we have to make it to the right
side wait let us get up okay wait then so easy and then go and then actually go up
steady there you go okay let me take a little right over here I think I can't okay wait is that
right where's the heck wait who can someone see or is it up left I think it's up left on the right
but okay we're going this way so I keep going left yeah I think it's this way
oh no oh am I slipping okay I can't jump because wait come a bit closer I can't jump oh
oh my gosh sorry sorry no no no don't worry
active okay active we're we're doing it oh my god okay we're gonna go ahead
over here we're shuffling gently easy easy steady no okay okay we're doing it and then
I'm gonna wiggle a little bit forward
uh-huh uh-huh easy easy
and then it's back to you yeah perfect oh my god right we're kneeling the sword for the first
time for three of us yeah membership should be really soon I'm already like oh you can
monetize by the end of the month I have membership
wait I'm not muted no I was okay so I have a toggle to mute that means uh okay I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry that means now I'm well you know you know uh this is terrible news but we're
allowed to celebrate your accomplishments you know we're not like I mean I did not say the most
ever okay okay we're doing it we're doing it wait can we pause movement so I can sit more
comfortable yeah of course of course yeah I'll be honest one day I would like to go piss if it's hot
wait what you don't sweat no no no I feel like I gained better with my pants off I'm sorry real
I mean I don't know I don't really stream wearing cold that's the best part about being a pizza
oh wow you don't have to do anything you don't have to do anything you're just like good morning
good morning good afternoon good evening status is there is there like any pause in that game
or something because I I'm such a kid I forgot to go piss before do you need to tinkle I'm kind of
okay have a little conversation we'll just hang out okay good thing go ahead go ahead
pants off and locked in yep we're I don't I don't mean to tear our own horns horns or anything
you know parade is a sin but I think we're doing all right I don't know we've failed once I mean we've
gotten pretty far if you ask me rather coordinated yeah I don't know how further up there is to go
like I've only made two one checkpoint but that wait have we not hit one checkpoint we haven't hit
one checkpoint well what about the sword no it's not a check okay well it was a checkpoint in my
heart eventually like look how I'm gonna believe it was you look down you can see how much we've come
look at five we've come I mean look at us we're doing fun oh wait you're up there oh my god
sonny what are you yeah isn't there like seven layers the hell or something like that oh this
is just the first layer oh that would be really cool she seemed the way yeah like I said we're only
on the bottom bread bit oh that sucks I hate the bread bit the bread okay I'm back welcome back
did you wash your hands with so
taking a piss I'll be back
oh my god no sorry I wow you call cotton okay no she is
I can like imagine it she's like pulling up it's like that you wash your hands you immediately
turns around and walks back look they don't call me mummy for nothing in this gen true
I'm back welcome back that was rather fast are you ready to progress yes I have a small apartment
we locked in locked in come on gamers we can do this we're we're totally going to reach the
first checkpoint for the industry real and true I don't know where actually we're so good at this
I wonder if the more people is it easier or harder because I feel like doing this solar
would be cheating because the whole point is to be chained to someone you can do this alone if it's
called chained again I don't know you could just change the loan who are you you're chained to your own
oh my god I get you up all in chain maybe oh maybe goodness gracious act you're scaring me
yeah I was gonna say
just jumping willy-nilly on like a very thin oh this is awkward to claim okay
we're claiming on the skull chain to your own sins actually real and
uh where are we supposed to go that's a great analogy are we supposed to land on that
rock with the veins straight ahead yeah yeah okay ready for something okay three two one
I don't know where do we even need to go we
twelve o'clock the veins on the rock look look look where the veins the veins oh what are they
called veins oh yeah okay I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry all right all right you ready yeah yes three
two one go shit shit that's not gonna make it no no no I think we all have to jump oh jeez
right okay okay okay okay okay okay we'll land up we'll land up we'll land up okay right
lined up on go three two one go
this one spinning you have to run uh when it lines up next you want to okay so right shift
let's you sprint remember that okay okay oh you can't yeah holding shift left yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay I make sure everyone's really close to the edge with me and we will sprint across right
okay not this one not this one next one three two one go run run run run run run oh my god
oh my god we're still broke what the heck how are we
real gamer girls yeah yeah we've got dialogue
we've got some lore
oh yeah I'm sorry I get to carry though if Timothy needs to shut the fuck up
and don't I give him a lesson
oh my wait so that was the first checkpoint
no
right this is a jump across right okay I will just jump across to where the ladder
is and then this sparks make sure you're nice and close to me I need to meet you it's perfect
yeah okay we're good oh my god I'll go into cheapen oh my god
heels jump reach heels cliff oh good job so they're cold watch out for the stuff watch out
watch out the spine oh my god I never even saw that yeah yeah yeah so like we got to time it
to go at the same time so if you could okay we can all switch really close I really got my head
in your ass oh we can't go inside each other that's good right all right next one yeah yeah
after this next one yeah yeah go go go go go go go and then pause and pause in between and between
oh no oh we're good oh we're good we're good we're good we're good we're good I'm on the wrong
side of the ladder hold on I'm on the wrong side oh my god okay I don't know how we did that but that
was good we didn't what happened did we stop no no no no it's because we were too close to when
we were above it yeah when we were above it sorry the bottom of us got clipped by it yeah
oh we survived though yeah that's the main thing yeah right I'm so glad we did not lose that
progress I would have been I would have been raging I don't play like raging just in games but no
okay we'll do the same thing where we need for folks okay go right next one after just
yeah after this man go go go
okay we're fine we're fine we're fine we're fine we know where to land we know where to land I think
we're maybe we go a bit earlier I think you're gonna have to like yeah I think it's on the initial
line yeah 100% penetration once the penetration is done because I'm sorry I don't I don't speak English
that well bro I don't know I'm not getting it wrong in what you said yeah no it is technically
that it's hard yeah something is moving from one place to another I mean intent of with the intent
of piercing no
penetration yes yeah you're not wrong you're not wrong that's absolutely correct oh no
oh uh piercing oh balls okay
thrust piercing I guess thrust okay okay after this who are we going
I think that one okay go go go go I think oh we're too late
no oh it's okay it's okay it's okay it's okay okay we've hardly lost any progress okay thank you game devs
for no oh oh oh pull me up I'm gone just grab the ladder grab the ladder grab the ladder I can't
grab it okay I'm on the ladder I'm on the ladder I'm on the ladder I'm on the ladder oh impaling
oh yeah so much this trust me impaling yeah I'm impaling okay it's not a common word to hear these
you know okay let's let's line up go under and then we talk for a bit okay game plan okay game
okay okay wait wait wait wait sorry sorry sorry that's me that's me okay no no I was high too
I mean I like I don't know how big the hitbox is some games like hitbox yeah I'm not gonna
test for it now okay okay I'm pretty close it's kind of like at me right now okay me and
yeah goodness oh we're sliding down the game you saw the game does not like that what you said
I thought I thought y'all gotta I think like what if I no no no you're pulling us off there
wait what if for me stronti is still falling where I'm on the ladder no no I'm like okay I'm
gonna jump down the ladder because y'all y'all you're like flying in the end oh yeah you're like flying
oh I was like straight up climbing on my let's go okay
Amy yeah great wait we're up into close we're ready okay oh shit we were oh wait I didn't I didn't know
we were going just for it I didn't know we were going for it and
okay okay okay I don't know we were okay we didn't count that tape we didn't count that time
that's that's no no no no we must count we must count we love count down shadow wizard money gang
we love count downs in this house
wait until I teach you guys what count down shadows in money gang
we love casting spells okay right we will we will focus up we're gonna come together we're
gonna sit on each other not now not not now sorry three two go go send us send us okay okay
okay safe safe that's what we like okay okay not this one not this one not this one not this one
Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, it's okay, it's okay.
Go, go, go, go!
Go!
Clay!
Too low.
Too low, too low.
Ahhh!
Too low, it was too low.
Oh, oh we see.
I got it, I got it, I got it.
Oh, nice save, nice save, nice save, nice save, nice save.
Wait, let me pull.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
I was down.
That was progress, though.
That was progress.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
At least we know like the threshold or like what is the...
The game is forgiving.
I was too low, like I wasn't inside of y'all.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I didn't even know how we could get things like that.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Hold on a minute.
OK, our heads are a little bit too close to the spikes.
Yeah.
Oh, gosh.
I can't.
This is broken for me.
My character was climbing in on space for so long.
Yeah, me too.
OK, I got this.
Easy peasy lemon squeezy.
What do you mean we've only reached one checkpoint?
What nonsense are you talking about?
I know that.
They hate to see pretty girls win.
Exactly.
They hate to see me eat.
OK.
No, no, no, no.
Oh, sorry.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
OK, OK, wait, wait, wait for the next one.
Three, two, one.
Go, go, go, go, send it, send it, send it.
OK, OK, OK, OK, we're good.
We're good, we're good.
Lovely, I love to see it.
I love the like, go, go, go, go, go.
Just send it, send it.
OK, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, next one, next one.
Three, two, go, go, just send it, just send it, just send it.
Yay!
Oh my god, we did it.
Yay.
We're trying to, it gets me every time.
You're so calm beforehand.
You're like, OK, no, not this time.
Everybody go, go, go, go.
Go, just please, go, just please.
Girl tonnage.
Is this a bedroom?
Yeah, how are people living up here?
Right, I'm stuck.
Oh, no, oh.
Are you just stuck through?
None of things, no.
Right, I sleep in, I'm sleeping in this one here.
This is my sleeping spot right here.
I can sleep underneath it.
Yeah, this can be like a bunker.
Yeah, a bunker bed, yeah.
OK, we going, right?
Use it.
I'm the ladder.
There's no spikes on this one.
OK, we're fine, we're safe.
There's no spikes on this ladder.
So it's not a challenge.
Surely we will not fail.
Surely.
Well, in this next part, it's fine, it's fine.
We just got to time our jump on it.
All together, like, the spikes.
All right, I'll do a countdown.
We all jump on and we all jump off at the correct time.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
OK, not this one, but next one.
Three, two, one, jump, and then jump.
Oh, no.
And four.
OK, OK, well, no, no, keep going, keep going.
Pulling, pulling, pulling, pulling, pulling.
I'm on, I'm on.
No.
No, this is all right.
OK, OK, I can't do anything.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Hold on, aim, aim, aim.
No, you're not going.
OK, OK, OK.
This is fun.
It's not that bad.
What if I need the game again?
I won't.
You can't fail.
You're going to fail.
You're stuck with us.
Last time I did, we got 2P2R.
OK, we're going to jump across.
I just got to go back on the skeleton.
Maybe.
I wonder if you can like speedrun it solo.
I'm sure there's like a category of like speedrunning in plays that do it solo.
Like once you've done the area I guess you know what's up because like obviously we don't
have to think about this one too much because we've done it so it really is a new location
unlocked right need to learn because those spikes on that ladder took us a hot second.
Yeah I think like the less it's a little easier but like it was the point if you don't have
someone change to you.
Yeah yeah.
Someone's like you could say we just got borned, but oh and I've taken us the wrong way excuse
me.
Oh turn around take this train back to the station.
Okay what way was it?
Okay it's to the right it's to the right that's where I went wrong is this way.
Oh no no no back to the green to Shaggy from Scooby-Doo.
Scooby-Doo.
Oh where are you?
Oh I'm sorry I'm pulling I'm pulling it's we are wait why aren't you coming up?
I don't know why.
Oh no.
Probably because we're like three person.
Is there not enough space to bring you up?
Okay oh no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no
Oh no.
I'm sure what did that happen?
It's ogre.
Well it's ogre.
Oh our chain is the hook.
Our chain is the hook.
It got on the two things.
Oh no right that's it find the angel wings where are they are they down here cause we're
flying.
Bro we're flying.
We're the angel wings.
I've never seen the angel wings playing this.
Oh my god this is a fun show.
I thought we had like you know what skills.
No we still have that.
I thought we had like oh see yeah actually the strat would be to like like would it load
into the checkpoint.
I don't think so cause that's no no no that's where you disconnected and that's where we're
going to spawn when you connect again.
So not checkpoint I don't think.
Bro okay okay it's fine it's fine what does this do.
I thought the the checkpoint is um if anyone's played it when you get to like the tomb area
so I thought that was like they really no we're nowhere close to it.
Wait someone says you got checkpoints turned on alright who would turn them off for one
close then say load checkpoint hell city heaven what wait okay hell maybe cause you're the
leader you can do it.
Load checkpoint you have not unlocked this checkpoint city you have not unlocked this
checkpoint what's hell you have not unlocked I've not unlocked any checkpoint apparently
apparently yeah if your character is stuck somewhere this option teleport you to the
nearest safe point highest point unlocked in case of significant fall teleport to the
highest point you've been.
Oh sorry we did do it we did get to it but oh thank gosh I'm surprised oh no thank.
I think we jumped too early cause like we were sliding off sideways yeah yeah I agree right
so we need to let it like delay a bit and then jump on cause it will go back to being
more flat.
Yeah cause I couldn't I jumped but I couldn't even like stand on it so I just fell.
Okay we love we love the dev team show to the dev team right not this one but the next
one and you have to be a bit delayed so three two kind of little go go go go go yeah yeah yeah.
Oh no I slipped I slipped I slipped.
It's okay it's okay.
Let me do the same thing as before instead of jumping it was too close so I kind of just
slipped.
Oh right wait right so if I just tell us to like keep going.
Keep going back to that point is that cheeky doodling or is this allowed?
No you know what it's fair game that's it's going back to our like we're here for progress
we're here.
We just chaos controlled this one.
Three places where we can do this.
Okay all right like that one.
So did we do it too early again?
To me I was too close and I was not I slipped because it made
the animation of like when you like you climb yeah it's just I was climbing on something
moving I just fell after like I was I guess I was too close I had to jump.
Okay we'll try and delay right now this one but the next one we'll do the delay again
like we'll do it super late that feels like okay three two one go again.
Don't worry don't worry don't worry pull pull pull.
I think we gotta jump where you're going.
How did you do that?
Oh my god if you're stuck press near safety.
You got it?
Okay cool.
Who?
I think we gotta jump when it's going off instead of when it's going in.
Like okay you meant like no like kind of thing.
Like okay like here.
Yeah okay okay okay.
Right everyone line up in a lane yeah like the laser okay this is gonna be interesting.
Like just when it start coming back.
Yes okay because when it's like this I just I just I can't jump.
It does the claim thing okay great.
This one that's coming up.
Three two one go.
Oh that was like that was like.
I didn't know we were doing that one.
Okay why is this one so hard?
I don't know the basis.
A little bit earlier?
Yeah earlier.
I didn't know we were jumping on that one.
Right not this one next one that's coming towards us.
Three two one.
Oh no I got caught I got caught.
Oh no no no it's okay we got it we got it.
Oh shit I'm down I'm down.
Oh shit.
Okay that was better though that was better though.
That was way better.
I just got caught.
I want to use your gamer instinct and then wait.
Yeah I think because of the latency when it feels right.
Yeah I think because of the latency.
Like pretend you're solo.
Okay okay.
It's when it feels right.
Okay then.
Okay not this one but next one.
Okay next one ready.
Okay.
Weeeeee.
Okay okay gamer instinct.
Oh no let me get caught.
I pulled so hard there.
Oh yes yes yes yes.
No way.
Wait wait wait get close to an edge.
Where are you?
We're under you.
You have to get close to an edge so you can pull us up.
Is it working or not pulling?
No no no we're under.
We're stuck under the.
I'm pressing E on you.
We're very far off.
Wait get close to the edge on the left for you.
Yeah.
Like here?
Yeah yeah yeah.
And a little bit more to the edge.
And then you just get in.
You're like very directly.
Is it pulling?
Wait it's not even pulling me.
I'm pulling someone.
Oh yeah wait wait wait.
I don't know how that happened but there you go.
Okay okay.
I'm still here.
To the edge.
I'm connected to Amy.
Why is it pulling me?
Yeah why can't I.
No you're pulling me you're pulling me.
Oh okay okay.
Yes yes yes just.
I pressed space bar to jump up.
No don't move just stay to the edge please.
Just yeah you need to be closer to the edge.
We're still under.
Press space bar if you can against something.
Oh yeah yeah.
Why is that?
Okay okay okay okay.
Oh hey we did it we did it.
We did it we did it we did it.
Okay okay.
Okay yeah.
We never have to do the swing again.
I mean I mean we never did it right.
We just happened to make it across.
Honestly.
Right.
I feel like there was a lot of glitching going on too.
Are we ready?
Who's got the squeaky's gamer chair?
I heard that.
It's me I have no money.
Okay let's move on.
Oh no.
Ready.
Three two one.
Okay.
That was a baby.
That's not easy.
Three two one.
Good good good good.
I got really excited for that jump though.
Uh.
Yeah across.
I have a bad feeling.
But let's just let's just go.
Is it this way?
It has to be look at that.
Oh oh yeah yeah it is it is.
We need to jump.
We're playing warp out.
I see poles.
We have to jump over those.
We have to jump on the platform.
No not yet.
She said jump and she's like.
She said she was just like okay.
Jump how high?
Okay okay.
Right not this one but next one.
So we will all go on that platform
and then we will you'll have to jump
when it's correct on your screen
because we can jump differently from each other
so it has to be correct on your screen.
Okay now we're going to get on the platform now.
On the platform and then jump
when it's correct on your screen.
Did we do it?
Did you get it?
Oh my god.
I don't know if I'm supposed to be.
Press E to pull us up.
Oh wait okay okay.
Oh yeah.
Oh my god I don't know how we did that
but I'm happy with that result.
Did I get you?
I can pull you up.
You can jump up 20 I think.
I'm spamming that space bar.
I'm spamming harder in my life.
Oh my head is getting there.
Did I get you?
Alright cool.
Alright we made it we chased it
but it was fun.
I love how I'm the one that missed the jump
and I got to this thing.
You literally saved our savior.
She's an angel.
No.
No I'm on the other side of the friggin...
I'm skilled.
I'm going in.
I missed the ladle.
Whoa.
Okay hold on.
Physics engine please.
Unity.
Everyone.
Right so this is a 3 2 1 jump
if I've ever seen one.
Everyone ready?
3 2 1 jump.
Beautiful.
Don't worry don't panic.
We're going to be okay Akati.
We're going to be okay.
We're going to just pull you up gently.
Don't panic.
No one panicked.
Oh don't panic.
It's okay.
Don't baby jump.
I'm trying to jump.
I'm spamming my space bar.
Why?
This pill function does not work.
Yeah.
It wants to work when it wants to.
I don't know if I have to like...
The WAS there.
Rotate around to get you up.
I literally...
It's not funny.
I'm kicking.
I'm literally pulling.
I'm kicking a bunch.
This is not happening.
I don't know what to do.
I'm back on.
I don't want to run yet.
I'm pulling.
I wonder if it's because the platform is so small.
It's not registering.
It looks like you're having a tantrum.
I've had enough of you guys changing me.
Goodbye.
Wait.
It's not even letting me pill you.
Oh no.
If I did load save,
surely we're not going to be...
We're not going to have to go back to that swing.
Oh thank goodness.
The game devs are actually nice.
I thought the game devs were evil,
but they're not, they're actually nice.
That is...
We love King's game devs.
10 out of 10 game because of King's game devs.
We're ready for the 3, 2, 1?
Yes.
Oh no!
3, 2, 1!
I have 3, 2, 1!
You said are you ready?
I was like, yep.
Okay, okay.
Ready?
3, 2, 1!
Don't worry, don't worry, don't worry.
Okay, right.
We'll aim for that platform, not the barrels.
3, 2, 1!
Beautiful.
Stunning, gorgeous teamwork.
I see a ladder here.
Yeah.
Oh, it is.
It's very hard to see.
We're going to do it.
Even though we're not out of the first section of the game yet,
we're totally going to do it.
I feel like this path is probably the hardest bit.
Really?
Are you completed it fully before?
No, no, I haven't.
Oh no.
It's like before, it's alright.
We have to move and jump.
Okay, so unfortunately,
timing isn't a thing as possible.
This is gamer instinct.
So...
Are you guys ready?
We're going...
Not this one, but next one.
Okay, let's just get a move on.
You have to jump when it's gamer time.
Remember, it comes back as well.
You're going to also jump behind.
Someone hit the...
No, it doesn't...
Okay, that wasn't bad.
I can't see when it's behind.
So when it's behind us,
you should turn around and walk back.
No, no, just turn your camera.
Okay.
We'll just go for it.
Move your mouse around.
That was me, that was me.
Let's try again.
No need.
Unless, unless you wait for it
to go all the way at the back
and then we run at it,
so we only jump one time.
Oh, that's a good idea.
This one, this one, this one, this one.
Go, go, go, go.
Chase it, chase it, and then jump.
That's it.
Don't worry, Lee.
No, no, no.
The ray?
Yeah.
Three, two, one.
Okay.
With this one, you have to jump on the trampoline
and land on the other trampoline
and then jump up to the box.
Okay.
Three, two, one.
Oh, shit.
We can't do that.
We'll get to that.
Oh, no.
That's all right. Easy, easy, easy.
No, this one, next one, next one.
We did it one time, we can do it.
Go, go, go, go, just go for it.
Okay, we go.
Easy peasy, don't worry about it.
Okay, that isn't rather easy.
Three, two, one.
Go.
Okay, and then this one,
we definitely have to sync up or else
we go up enough movement.
I think we gotta run too.
Oh, like, like, run.
Oh.
Except to run at the same time.
Okay.
On.
Go.
Three, two, one.
Oh, it's done and beautiful.
Gorgeous.
I love it, I'm here for it.
It's out, I'm getting pulled.
What the fuck?
What did I just do?
That's good, that's good.
It's a joy ride.
Everything is perfect.
I literally went to pull you up
and all of a sudden we're flying.
I don't know how we did that,
but I'll just let it happen.
One of Hal's most convenient modes
of public transport.
Yeah.
Oh, look at the view.
It's so beautiful.
So the entire...
What? A random truck?
Yeah.
Who has their license?
Not me.
I mean, kind of, for certain vehicles.
Oh.
These vehicles.
The Carvys?
I've got an achievement.
Boat, tractor.
Whoa.
This basically is like a tractor.
I can't get out of it.
For me.
I got a license.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
It's literally you driving.
Oh, my God.
Yes.
We look like we're like...
I forgot the word.
I'm not good in English.
We're farmers.
Joy ride.
Very nice.
Don't be scared, guys.
Back it up.
Is it fast enough?
Oh, there's gas.
I'm a great driver.
We're sitting like we did something bad
and we got grounded.
We're like, we're sorry, Mom and Dad.
We didn't mean...
Yeah, exactly.
This is going to the Dr. Phil Ranch.
What was those accusations?
What was those kids getting?
We're going to the ranch.
Send you to the ranch.
You never doubted me.
That was amazing.
You got your license, we never doubted.
You really did get your license.
We touched the weekend.
A new hand has touched the weekend.
Okay, so like, what the fuck?
Right, so I see...
What?
Yeah, it turns and you move.
So you have to jump around.
As it's spinning, yeah, I have to jump around.
Like, jump onto the next flat surface.
It consistently spins.
One, two...
Does it consistently spin left?
No.
It spins every three seconds.
Like, spin one, two, three...
We'll take a side each.
No?
Wait, we can grab on like monkeys.
It's a grab one.
Oh.
Did we just go for it?
Just go for it.
Grab.
No, it's not grab like monkeys at all.
You can grab.
Just jump when it changes the corner.
Okay, it's like playing skip.
We're a hop, skipping away.
Drag me up, drag me up, drag me up.
It's okay, it's okay.
Oh, so close.
No, no, no.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Okay, there's two of us up.
We're dead.
Sorry, but we're actually such a dream team.
We're making so much progress.
I don't care what anyone says.
That was quite clutch.
A little bit of Mario Kart.
Super Mario.
Yeah, the car was good.
Okay, water.
What's going on?
Jump on one and then go on the next one.
Yeah.
I thought we could just do it from here.
I just take my buddy with me.
That's fine.
There we go.
Wait, come here.
Oh.
Hello.
Guys, we're in touch.
By chance.
There we go.
Oh, it slipped.
Why does it not?
Oh, right, well, it's fine.
No, no, just launch.
Okay, okay, okay.
And you come, and you come.
Okay.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, there we go.
Wait, I'm out for you guys.
Oh.
You can climb, you can climb.
You can fly, you can fly.
Come on.
Why?
It never lets me pull you up properly.
Whoa.
I complained about it and it worked.
Yeah, exactly.
See, all your problems are solved by complaining out loud.
Yes, your problems right now.
Oh, false.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
We got this, we got this.
If it'll let you up.
Oh, hold on.
I don't know why it won't let me up, please.
Am I pulling?
We're both pulling.
Let me climb.
Hold on, right, we're down.
Why?
Am I even fucking pulling?
What am I doing?
I don't think so.
I don't know if the game's bugging out for Mismo.
She's like, you're falling.
Yeah, like flying.
And then I fell.
I'm trying to pull you up.
Oh, no.
There we go.
Standing in these paths, I feel like I slip off all the time.
Oh.
Here it comes.
How can I make it worse?
I'm making this so much worse.
Everyone climb up and then go on that first platform thing.
Because the game is not having it with Mismo right now.
It hates you.
It literally hates you.
Oh, no.
And now, Amy, it won't let me pull you.
There we go.
Right, okay, we're going to stay on this platform
until we're ready to jump up, okay?
We're going to line up like good little frogs.
Okay, all in a row.
Four little frogs ready to hop in.
Three, two, one.
Under this platform.
Oh, shit, my head.
What the fuck?
Can I grab?
I'll say three frogs.
Thank you.
Okay, okay.
Four little frogs ready to hop
in.
Three, two, one.
Oh.
I'm so freaking short.
What the hell?
I'm short.
My model got to be short.
Okay, no, this one.
No, this one, next one, next one.
Okay.
And there's four little frogs
waiting on the wall.
They're going to jump up
like hip-hop.
Jump!
Thanks for my model is short.
I jumped.
There we go.
One more, one more.
Look at all I did.
Okay, proof that frogs are awesome.
We love it here.
I'm always in money.
Okay, that's actually a rather big jump.
So I think we need to go back on this platform
and jump over with it.
No, you can make it.
I think.
Yeah.
Go, go, go, please.
Ta-da!
Very good, very good.
Okay, now we have the pillars
of the Colosseum.
Okay, right.
Well, I guess just three, two, one.
Three, two, one.
All right.
No, wait, wait.
Oh, no!
I wasn't.
Easy, easy.
Steady.
Oh, no.
Can you get up?
The pool mechanic in this game.
Oh, shit.
I walked backwards as I was pulling.
Okay, we managed, we managed.
Okay.
Are we ready?
Three, two, one.
Oh!
Okay, that was a better one.
Okay, three, two, one.
Wait, are we going the right way?
We're going down instead of up.
Oh, no, we're going the right way.
No, this is correct. This is all right.
Yeah, it's just dipping and then we go back up.
Three, two, one.
Ah.
No, don't worry, don't worry.
I got it, I got it.
I'm good.
Three, two, one.
Okay, we're actually.
Very good.
It's just regular jumping at this point.
Yeah.
That seems rather...
That's a big one.
Three, two, one.
That looks pretty regular.
Yeah, I don't really need to do a countdown for these jumps.
Yeah, yeah.
This one's like a hate jump.
That one's okay.
Oh, god, fucking damn it.
God damn it being from Europe.
No!
The ping.
It says my ping is 400 on top.
It says 400 in...
Where does this say?
What number does it say?
For me, it's 3984.
Oh, mine's 3942.
Guys, guys, that's how far up we are in me.
We're dumbasses.
Oh, my god.
Don't include me in that wee, guys.
I'm the only one who's told you.
That's embarrassing.
I'm the only one who's told you, okay?
That's not me. I'm not part of this.
That's embarrassing.
Don't listen to our thing.
It's literally horrible.
Anyway, back to the claiming.
Yes, the claiming.
Right. We'll do a three, two, one.
Okay.
Three, two, one.
That was definitely
a critical moment.
I think that's just a jump.
Oh, no.
Before we jump on the trampoline, can I do something real quick?
My V-Tube is lagging a little bit.
Yeah, of course.
I can't believe I thought that was ping.
So 396 years ago.
Oh, I genuinely thought that was ping.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, that's quite...
How many meters is that above sea level?
Isn't that a thing?
Oh, are we under sea level?
Oh, like, there's...
I'm looking ahead
and there's moving lasers above.
Just let you guys should know.
Like, way up there.
I don't even know if we're going to reach the...
You know, I have a feeling that, like,
okay, don't take this the wrong way,
but, like, in...
I feel like I'm built with a big chain on it.
Like, do it with people you really care about.
Yeah.
I wouldn't do it with, like, a stranger or anything like that.
I think that would...
Yeah, no, that would be a really good, like, sleepover.
Whenever we get in the VNU off-collab,
where you're all chained together, come on.
We're waiting on a...
We've had the VNU off-collab
where DK quite literally showers me.
Aw.
She showered me.
Wait, was it wholesome or was it...
I was really...
I was really drunk.
I was really, really drunk,
and she didn't want me to sleep in our shared bed
with my clothes that I've been wearing,
so she was like, going to shower.
I was like, I can't shower, I'm drunk.
So she showered me.
Aw, that's kind of...
Everyone needs a friend that will help you
shower when you're drunk this night.
Let's play.
I like how she was like,
you're not coming into the bed with those dirty clothes.
I'm like, like, mom and I'm dad.
Aw.
That's so sweet.
Okay.
Yeah.
How are we doing, Acty?
It's better.
It's better?
Yeah.
Is it?
That giggle didn't seem so sure.
Well, let's say the game
is killing your stream.
It's a game.
I'm not lagging unless
the thing is open.
I thought my V2 was open,
and then I de-tab from the game
for moving fine.
Wait, wait, wait.
You might want to put your...
This can help.
You might want to put the game as, like, window
instead of full screen.
Yeah.
Yeah, that could help.
And also if you use...
Spote too?
I'm not sure you use display,
like, it'll be as you use...
I hate the source before you put on.
Yeah, no.
I'm not going to put display.
I'm going to, like, dox myself.
Yeah, definitely.
Oh, right. Or window.
Because then it still captures the game,
but not, you know.
Yeah.
Window takes less than game?
I believe so.
I could be stupid, but...
No, at least I'm going to do that then.
Well, it's a little probable.
I have no idea.
Yeah, that I don't know.
That is display.
When was the last guy...
No, last time you guys were actually
on the trampoline.
Oh, gosh.
See?
That's a loaded question.
I had a childhood friend
that had a trampoline,
and I jumped on it.
My tail...
My tailbone
always used to hurt
because I think I broke it.
You know, I can't remember.
There's, like, a really tiny bone
at your tailbone,
and it cracks really easily,
and I think that unironically broke it.
Yeah, I know, because my mum broke it.
Yeah, I think I did that
on the trampoline,
and I'm scared of trampolines now,
like, oh, no.
I used to get scared of,
like, because depending on the trampoline,
have you ever seen the big rectangle ones?
Oh, yeah.
My cousin had that one,
and I used to get scared of, like,
jumping and landing in between
where the springs were.
And I remember, because I landed
in...I landed my leg
through one of the gaps,
and, like, it cut.
Because it's obviously metal.
I'm, like, always, like, terrified to jump on them again.
Aww.
I feel like I just asked
a very insensitive question somehow.
What, but a trampoline?
Yeah.
No, not at all.
It's even like everyone has some panic.
Oh, really?
It means I feel bad.
I like trampolines.
But now the trampolines, like,
they're all safe now, so it's better.
Yeah.
I was on one, like...
I don't have one,
but I think the last time I was on one
was maybe, like, two years ago.
I did gymnastics for, like, the longest time.
Oh!
That's cool.
I quit because I'm getting old.
There's the hockey ball.
No. Retiring.
That's actually better. Thank you so much.
I didn't know. Oh, my God.
I've been streaming for four years.
I didn't know that.
I've been streaming for three weeks.
But that's true.
I'm three years old.
Baby.
Yes, baby.
Are we ready?
Actually, the longest time we're ready,
we go to the big rock, right?
Yeah.
I'll come to the side.
Three, two, one, go.
Three, two, one.
Actually...
Never mind.
Wait, I was not ready, and I'm the one on it.
Anyway, let's go.
Don't worry, I'm pulling, pulling, pulling.
Okay.
We did it anyway. We did it anyway.
Yeah, that's fun.
We just won anyway.
So we gotta wait until these line up in the middle.
And just run.
I know how it lines up.
I assume we just sprint across when it lines up.
Yeah, so we have to start
as it's about to form the bridge.
We have to start on the left side, then.
We have to start on the left side.
Not this one, not this one.
Next one.
And then it's sprint, shift to sprint.
Three, two, one, go.
And then sprint, sprint, sprint.
Oh, shit, oh, shit.
Go for it, go for it, go for it, go for it.
I almost had it.
Don't give up.
I can't believe the whole premise
of this game being chained together
was our demise. I can't believe it.
We have a chance, we have a chance, we have a chance.
Do we?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And now what?
Now what?
On the right.
We're gonna rotate around with it.
A little too early but I like the enthusiasm.
I like the enthusiasm.
No way.
Yeah, no.
Yeah, real game or move right there.
That was very...
That's fine, you did it.
Oh, I know, we should wait.
I think we gotta wait again.
These will disappear.
So, I think, yeah.
Whoever's at the end should...
Johnny, go for it.
Like, I'll go first though.
Yeah.
Wait till it disappears and then act these steps on it.
Uh-huh.
And then we just sprint for it.
I'm on it? Yeah.
Yeah, it's when you get off but we have to...
Yeah, it's when you get off so wait for Johnny's signal.
I'm ready when you are.
Yep.
Send...
When you're ready.
I say go or...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
They go.
Wait, I think you have to step up.
Step again?
Okay, I'm stepping on it right now.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Shift, make sure you're holding shift.
Make sure you're holding shift so you're running.
Try to avoid claiming if you can.
Avoid the claiming.
Ah, shit.
Yeah.
Oh my god, I'm like claiming but...
Stop claiming.
I think we're okay, I think we're okay.
Don't wanna...
Go, go, go!
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm sorry, I screamed.
Let's go!
This way, this way.
Yep, yep, yep, yep.
Ready?
Yeah.
Ring around the rosy.
The pocket full of posies.
A tissue, a tissue.
We all fall down.
Apparently it's about the black plague in Europe.
It's okay, I'm gonna play with them.
Oh.
Okay, are we ready?
I wanna just jump, we just gotta learn.
Yeah, just the 3, 2, 1 jump on this one.
Yeah.
3, 2, 1, yeah!
Whee!
3, 2, 1, yahoo!
We're like Mario and Johnny.
Mario and Johnny.
Okay, this one's a bit big
but I think we'll manage, right?
3, 2, 1, whee!
Beautiful stunning gorgeous 10 out of 10.
Love it.
Let's go!
We got another lift.
Whee!
I love elevators.
Oh, it's already going up.
Whee!
Very, very good.
This is so nice.
What happens if we all kiss and change?
We pissed.
Oh, this is where I got up too.
Yeah, this is like the checkpoint you did.
Yeah.
Oh, there's bats.
Oh, I'm getting stuck.
So this is unfamiliar territory for me.
I don't know where to go from here.
Oh, so nice.
It looks safe.
Question mark.
It kinda gives me like Skyrim crypt vibes.
Ah, yeah.
We swim?
Well, I am a water type beacher.
I don't know about you, but I'm water type.
So...
Oh, we have to go underneath.
Oh, can we drown? I hope not.
Oh, well, I mean, we're already dead.
True.
No, you got...
Yeah.
That was cute.
We had a bit of a bath.
What was that? Oh my god.
Boss fight.
It feels like Elden Knight.
Is it close to you? Yeah.
Dark Souls boss...
HP shows up.
Oh, so the HP bar spawns in...
We're being very upset.
So it says yes, you can drown.
Well...
Oh, okay. Well, we...
We didn't drown.
We died twice.
Yeah, we didn't even drown.
We're gonna die square.
I don't...
I don't think...
Oh...
Hmm...
Okay.
I'm laking it so far.
Oh, Angel Wing!
Wait, come...
Are you scared by Angel Wing?
Oh, Angel Wing's.
Yeah, yeah, let's get it.
Whee!
You'll be for longer glades when you fall.
Oh...
So you could try to like save your jump, I guess.
save your jump I guess. Why are we there's buttons over there? Where? Take a follow. We
follow you Ms. Muxay. Oh, oh, you mean there's really big a red light. I wonder if we have
to coordinate to hit it? There's another button up. There's other button. There's four button.
I think maybe we need to like light them up. This one here or up. Oh yeah we do but the
other one over there is also not yours so we should probably go get that one. There's
that one here. Someone up here? Oh yeah. Hold on. No, I'll kill you. Yeah, I'm cheesy dude
alone. I'm just filling you up. Help me. Ah, I missed my note. Help me. Thank you. Oh no,
because I was walking backwards trying to pull. Okay, wait. We can just jump for this one. Three,
two, one, go. Yeah. Easy peasy lemon squeezy. Then we'll just jump down. Three, two, one. Three,
two, one. Okay, now what? Oh, crack. Is there? Oh. Once press the button. Thankfully that's
our biggest enemy. Our biggest one is this. Right. Well, we can at least jump on like a
like a roll. Okay, three. I think time it. Yeah. We can jump on this and one go right. Three,
two, one. Spider time. Okay, great. No. I mean, we can go one and one, right?
That is true. I don't think the chain is gonna. Okay. Stawning? Yeah. Oh yeah, okay. Okay. I
thought you were going to get hit. No, no, no, no. Right. We're not. This one. This one. Go, go, go.
I will have time. I will have time. That's okay. That's okay. Come through here now. Yeah, that's good.
This one's going to be way harder. Wait, careful. Up, up, up. Go, get up, get up. Oh yeah, good call. Good
call. Oh wait, we can. Okay, we just need to go a little to the left. Wait, wait, wait. We can
just jump. Wait, wait, wait. Look, look, look, look. Come to the left, actually. Just, just, we'll
all start climbing. Yeah. And then we'll push to the left. Okay. Right. Three. Oh, well, yeah, okay.
Well, I was going to take it. Oh, nice. Go, Timothy.
Uh, Gameran's saying. Oh, I have not.
No, no, no, no.
Why does it do this? Yeah, oh, yeah, I pulled myself up. Okay. Okay. Easy, PZ, 11. We have a lot of
upper body strength to be pulling each other like that. Yeah, right. Very ripped. Okay. We still need
to kill, but we have to do it on our own. I think this is a gamer instinct one because I think I
can't count this for paying, so. No, I think you have to count it and then we see our first opening
since that end of the count. Uh, I think we can do like it's going to be different for everyone,
but like as soon as you said go, we're going to look for the first one. Okay, so just as a
rotate one, two, three, four, and then we'll go on the fourth rotation. Does that make sense? I'll
say the rotation twice. Is that or should we just gamer instinct it? I want a gamer instinct.
Three, two, one. Can you go? Okay, yeah. Yeah, that's fine. Okay, then we're overthinking it.
Oh, what the hell? Okay. You slipped, PZ, 11, PZ. I slipped? I don't know. For me, I'm ice cream now,
it's just crazy. Okay, we have to go on a carousel, which we'll jump on. And then just jump over
the lasers. We're gonna need to go to the one that's coming here, right? This one? This one? This one?
I guess so. I mean, it's just because I don't think, I don't think the one we were on was about to.
Big jump, big jump. Gamer instinct it. There's no tamer on this one. Oh, shit. No, that wasn't me.
That wasn't me. That wasn't me. I'm sorry. Okay. Did we get the car again? I want to read the car.
Whoa. Oh, that's going to water again. That's fun. Oh, wait, can the checkpoint take us to the top?
I think so. I think so. I'll fill the check. I just wanted to swim. We will. Oh, cheeky swimming.
Oh, there we go. There we go. Easy. Yeah. Well, we can't be ready, but yeah, this is definitely
gamer instinct one because I can't tame the lasers the way it can be done, but we can at least jump
on this. Yeah.
Ready, go.
Okay. Surely we won't mess up twice in a row.
Lovely. Right. Where do we go tonight? Oh, here, here.
Oh, this one, this one. Is this going to be close enough? What? Go, go, go. Isn't it? Isn't it that?
Oh, I think so. I'm pulling and trying not to fall off it. I think we had to go at...
Hold on. I am pulling you. I am. I have the idea. Hold S, I think, to like swim back.
All right. Oh. No, Ms. Must teaching us this like an hour and... Okay, hold on. Jump. Get ready to
jump, Amy. I totally forgot about that. It's so good from my POV. As I, I mean, I mean, you're
butt, you're butt, Amy. You're butt, you're butt, you're bodacious butt, Amy. You're tishy.
I know where. No, we are definitely, Ms. Mom was right. We are supposed to jump on
that third one. It looks like the distance is going to make it, but we must have faith.
We have faith in the demoness. She knows what she's doing. She lives here, okay?
Ah, yes. I live here. Why? Yes, of course. It should be coming around. Yep. I'm getting ready.
Nice to come here during that. Three, two, one. Oh, I missed. I missed. No, no, it's okay. The way,
the way, the way. Okay. Gorgeous. Gorgeous. Gorgeous. Lovin' it. The way. I got you. I got
you. Stunning. Okay, there is a... Oh, we missed her. Okay. We are going to have to just go around.
We are going to have to jump around this. Don't worry, we got it. Yeah, we got it.
Gameran. If you're stuck. Stop it, tips. You're taunting me.
It's like, it keeps it. If you're stuck, press near safe location. Give us a chance,
okay? Give us a chance. Yeah, I gotta try first. Oh, wait, the ass is right there.
Yeah, and the, the, it's very, um, uh, very calm, calm down. The glue is maximum.
Okay, we gotta jump this next one too. Yes, yes, yes. Ready? Remember, we can just push through
this. Yeah. And then we get off of the platform. We've got three achievements.
I think it's open here. Yeah, just then we're out.
There was 16 achievements in this game. So if we have three achievements so far,
by my calculations, we're like, I don't know. Ish done. Like, okay. Do we need to tame this,
or can we just go for it? I think I can just go for it. Yeah, I think there's enough space between.
Unless, unless, unless. I think it's the chain that's like, ooh, mess up. Okay. I don't know how
I've managed this, but I made it worse. I've made it terribly worse. Everything. Wait, I,
don't wait. I got it. I got it. Trust me. Trust me. Trust me. Trust me. We keep falling off.
We keep falling off, man. We fell though. Oh, good grief. I wonder what hidden,
there must be so many hidden secrets in this game that. No. Oh, sorry. Sorry. Right. That's okay.
No, you're right. I can grieve the loss of our progress later. Right now we gotta make progress.
Uh, right. Okay. One gamer instinct. Yeah. That's all right. The gamer extent was a gaming.
The gamer, I can't believe it. I can't believe you're, I can't believe you didn't come out of the
womb holding an Xbox 360 controller. They're just shocking behavior, shocking behavior.
I can't believe you're, when your mum gets like a belly scan and you're holding like a Gameboy
advanced in your hands, I can't believe it's just shocking. It's the new gen just not made like
out there. No. Just don't make them like how they used to. Okay. Big jump. It doesn't look like we
can make it, but we still can. Oh, okay. Well, it was a bit early. I was a bit early. I was a bit
early. I was rather early on that one going to be honest. Oh, please. So I was on it, but the pool
was too much. Jumping so early on that one. Stop it. I mean, we could probably shift for the
specific one, but shift. By we, I mean me. I went, I went with you. Look, sorry. You know,
would you jump if your friends jumped off a cliff? Would you jump? Oh, yes. I'm gone.
Wee. I'm away. Me too. Okay.
It's too easy. Please. They can't handle it.
Then big jump. Gorgeous. Stunning. I love it. The master pieces coming together. Okay. We need to
jump, but not, not too early. Oh, close enough. Close enough. Close enough. I'll take it. I'll take
it. No, it's all good. I'm pulling. I'm pulling and pressing S at the same time.
No, there may be a jump. Very good. There may be a jump very shortly. I think we're going to do
right. We need to do the full rotation. So we do need jump.
Wee. Gorgeous. 10 out of 10. Yeah.
Now we can stare at S until we have to jump next. Oh, I love this part. It's my favorite.
The highlight of the game. This is secretly the highlight of the game.
I got two underscreen shots right now.
I had no idea it was that close. I had no idea. I was in the opposite position. Okay. Okay. Okay.
I have my tension into the ass.
Distracted by booty cheeks. Oh, well, I was going to try and make a pun out of this.
The word distract and ask, but it didn't really work. Uh, it's like going to be
distracted. Yeah, you know what? Yeah. I can see the vision. Yeah, that's like a word.
Okay. Now we are going to have. How did we fail last time? I think we were too far away from
each other's chains. I think all of us just jump at the same time. We do the three, two, one thing.
Yeah. Three, two, one.
It's okay. It's just so small. I wonder is it too far that we
like one by one? Is it too far if we do like one by one? No, I would say one by one should probably
work because like if the chain is one by one, maybe not, but I think perhaps.
This is a difficult one. Hold on. Everybody get close.
Oh, shit. We made it. What's wrong with this jump?
Hmm. I think if I jump first, we're falling all the way down in the bottom of the map.
I think I was on it. That's on the edge of the chain needs to jump first because it needs to be a
no pun intended chain reaction. I mean, look at all the progress we've made in general. So I'm not
even mad. I'm not even mad. Sorry. We have a little swatch. Well, that would be terrifying to feel
like the force of the air against you as you fall to the ground gently.
Yeah. I mean, I mean, it didn't splat onto the floor. So it's gently.
I would love falling from the sky. Are you being skydiving? I want to. I've done like paragliding.
Oh, Paragliding. Wait, which one's paragliding?
That's the one where it's like, it's like, it's not a plane, but like you just an air
suit type thing in the bulb. Oh, with a parachute.
With the air currents and that, like it can take you really far.
Oh, shit. Okay. Oh, yeah. I don't know if y'all are pressing shift or not, but shift
makes you go further. So I press lunches. Oh, okay. I think I think Strani has to go first on
that one. We keep failing because you're at the front of the chain. Yes. Yes, because I'm getting
almost messed up. Excuse me. Excuse me. I'm embarrassed.
And then we go jump.
Strani, Strani. I'm ready. I follow you. Three, two, one. Oh, okay. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. I'm happy.
Okay. We're good. We're good. We're good. We've got big, big jump. Oh, here, here, here.
Big jump. Well, it's actually not as big as that other one. This one's a lot easier. Oh,
the pole. The pole. Please. Will someone think of the pole? The galvanized steel beams. Please get
out of my face. Galvanized steel beams. Oh, literally. Are you borrowed from your auntals?
Okay. One at a time. Wait, wait, wait. The order of the thing. Wait. Okay. Wait, it's right. Yeah.
And edging gently. Edging gently. We did. So when we all jumped on, we just make sure you press
spacebar when you jump as well to grab onto the log. That's what I'm saying. It's like,
is it too far if we jump one by one? I think we can all jump together and just hold on to the log.
No, because like the climbing space won't be enough for all of us, I don't think. See?
Oh, I'm sorry. No, no, you're fine. You're fine. You're fine. You're fine. You're fine. Right. One more
try and if we don't do it, we're rage quitting. That's all I'm saying. I know my blood pressure
isn't artificially raised higher than it normally is right now, but that's because I'm a gamer. I want
to win. But I'm not going to, I'm not going to torture these lovely girls that have agreed to
collab with me via gameplay, via gameplay of the same thing over. Do you know what the definition
of insanity is? The definition of insanity. Repeating the same thing over and over again.
I'm not going to force it. I'm not going to force it. I like insanity.
Are you mad scientist apparently? I was doing a trick shot. I was just, I was just checking
your pain tension. Okay. Miss, ma'am, Miss Captain. Three, two, one. Okay. I'm getting held back.
I think we all need to jump at the same time. I'm getting. All right. One more chance. One more
chance. I'm not addicted. I'm not addicted. Right. What we have to do is we all have to jump at the
same time because when I leap forward, I get pulled back. If that makes sense, we do need to
because then I just sometimes when I jump, it doesn't like I press this baseball, but this
doesn't happen anywhere. Yeah.
Okay. All together. I heard that car horn. Right. Three, two, one.
I always hit that pole. I got you. Thank you. Okay.
Watch out. Oh, yeah. You did it. Okay. We all have to jump at the same time because it's not
going to work. Okay. Three, two, one. Go. Oh, that was perfect. That was good. That was perfect.
That was so juicy. That was so gorgeous. That was so five star Michelin. Oh, no, is it one?
Oh, no, it is Michelin stars. Like how they made fancy food.
Yeah. The fanciest food I've ever had is chicken burger and chips. That's what that's fancy.
Chicken burger and chips. I've never tried like caviar or anything that's considered.
No, me neither. I love caviar. Okay. This is it. This is the defining factor. If we reach
quit or no, we're all going to group up. Okay. So it is one and one. Wait. Oh, one big jump together
because we're pulling. It is because we pull too much. We can all jump on the log and grab it at
the same time because we don't have clipping in this game. So I will count down and on go we jump
or whenever I say we. Okay. All right. And we and you must grab the log. You must press space bar.
Okay. Three, two, one. Grab that. It's stunning. Gorgeous. Exact same thing. We're going to do it.
Right. Three, two, one. And then grab. We must grab the log. We must grab the log.
Okay. Good job. Good job. Good job. Gorgeous. Gorgeous. Easy. Edge the log. Edge the log.
I hear something like a buzzing. That's just the log. Don't worry. The log's having a good time.
Okay. I don't know the water. Why is the water squirting?
Okay. Are we ready? Three, two, one. Go. And grab the log. Grab the log. Grab the log.
I did it. I did it. We did it. We did it. Oh, my God. Yes.
I was so stressed. Here we go. Break time. Break time. I need to breathe. Have a brief. We did it.
Hydration check. Hydration check, gamers. Hydration. We're doing it. We're doing it. We're doing it.
We're doing it. Oh, my God. I was like, bro, we don't make this on region, but because we made it,
I got another one in me. Chief, put me back in. Put me back in. I got another one.
Well, I'm eating a bit of my food that went cold. Oh, no. Oh, no. What are you eating?
Um, it's budak ramen. Oh, budak ramen.
Budak ramen. It's like noodles. It's the carbonara ones, but I prepared it in a very specific way.
Oh, no. Wait, wait, wait. This is perfect. Actually, I bothered my members by sending them the exact
way step by step how I do it. Oh, real and true. Here we go. Let's go. We have the secret recipe.
I love keeping recipe as a cooking Vtuber. I never tried that. So first time I do budak,
I might just do that one. Oh, please. Please. It's so good. I never had the budak.
Okay, we will let you eat. Oh, I don't know what creme fraiche is.
It can be like, uh, you can use like, I guess you can use sour cream as a substitute, but
that wouldn't say so. Let me do it like a viewer check if people know what creme fraiche is.
It's like, I don't think it's an Aussie thing. I don't think we have this in Australia.
I don't know. I know that you're saying French right now. I understand the French,
but is that just like, not whipping cream, but like cream? It's cream. It's not really because it's
closer to sour cream. Like cream cheese or sour cream? Sour cream. It's smoother. Oh.
Yeah, it's like, it's between sour cream and cream cheese.
Mmm. Oh, okay. So it's like, okay, I see what you've done.
Oh, it's so good. I'm like, I'm holding back. I'm like, I'm holding back.
I'm sad it's gone cold for you though.
Like it's gone cold now. That's okay. I'm not picky.
Right, as long as it tastes good and it satisfies.
I think I'm the least picky person ever.
I could have a whole pizza fall on the floor. I do not care.
Five second rule. That's real. You've extended it to 10 second rule.
Right, I think. I'm sorry for making you guys sit here. No, you're fine. It's good to eat.
We've got, I would say we've probably got another 10 minutes and then we'll see how far,
but if we keep dying at something, I'm not going to hold you guys hostage any longer.
I'm having fun.
Yeah, give me a stretch whenever.
Yeah, the hypnosis help is ready.
Yeah.
I'm glad they said like bulky.
Okay. Well, just do the three, two, one, because this is the best method.
It's not filled us so far. Okay. Three, two, one.
Yeah, this is like literally the best method. I don't care.
My name says I don't care if you're tired or listening to me saying it's working.
Right. Three, two, one.
Go. Oh, I've got a big say there. Okay. Very good. Three, two, one.
Go.
Three, two, one. Go.
Nice night. Three, two, one. Go.
I'm going to hear this in my dreams tonight.
All right. Three, two, one. Go.
Hey, we're gorgeous. Gorgeous. Gorgeous. Three, two, one. Go.
Yeah, I'll do it extra Scottish this time. Three, two, one. Go.
Go, go, go. Three, two, one. Go.
We're doing it in French now.
Three, two, one. Go.
That was a good French. No, congrats.
Okay, we're going to do in Spanish next. We'll come up to the next, but for Spanish.
Okay. Very nice. Okay, on the sword. I can sing my sword, sword.
Oh, this is a big jump actually. Okay, maybe we'll do it in English because this is a bit of an
awkward one. Okay. On the cross, we jump. Okay. Yeah. Three, two, one. Go.
Oh, I didn't. I appreciate it. I appreciate it. Hold on. I can pull you up. I can pull you up.
Oh, thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Right. That's just a jump. That's not even how. That's not good.
And then again, three, two, one.
Whoops. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Oh my God. It's literally us because there's four of us.
Oh my God. What one are you? Tag you. Which one are you?
I'm the one right there in the corner. I'm on my knees. Always.
I'm standing. I'm standing at the back. I'm like standing in the back.
I want to be the little gremlin on the...
Okay. I'll be the first. I'll be like, come on, guys.
Don't you want to play this game? What do you mean? It's really frustrating and people hate it.
Well, come on, guys. Like, come on.
Wait. Strongly. That means that our statue versions are literally ass to ass.
Ass to ass. I don't mind if I do.
I'm going to draw that.
On his back to back.
As to ass.
Okay. We're going to wiggle. We're just going to wiggle.
We don't need to jump. We don't need to do anything.
That's less difficult than the bones, technically.
Wiggle, wiggle. Wiggle, wiggle, wiggle.
I'm going to make you laugh and looking at us.
Oh no.
Bird's eye view going. Get that bird's eye view going.
What?
Oh, I'm turning. I'm apparently...
I'm doing a 360 by accident. I don't know how I managed that one.
Oh, easy. Easy.
Steady.
All right. We're good. We're good.
Steady. Okay. Follow this and we'll...
Easy. Easy.
Slow and steady wins the race.
Do you guys not know the turtle?
The turtle? Is that the tortoise and the hare story?
Tortoise and the hare?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
That's right. The toy just won because he picked his thing.
And it is a life story.
I think it was while the hare was being cocky and thought he could beat the
tortoise.
There you are.
Don't get too cocky, girls.
You heard it.
You heard it here first.
Don't get too cocky.
Don't get cocky.
Are we almost there?
Okay. Right.
Okay. I needed to look ahead because I was like, bro, we've been on this.
Yeah. I was like, when did the ride stop?
I feel like we're playing Sonic Heroes.
Do you know the rails?
Yeah. Oh my God.
Rail Canyon?
Yes.
Yeah. I hate that level.
My favorite.
I always fall off on it.
Man, I fell off.
Okay. Okay.
That was superb.
I love when we're not in one.
Oh, wait.
This isn't...
I don't like...
I got maze.
Okay.
Mermaid time.
Who won?
Right.
My mermaid power is...
My one has a red tail.
Maze got green tail.
I have a orange tail.
I want a mint tail.
No, that's not true.
I want a black tail.
Oh, yeah.
Hell, yeah.
Right, mermaids.
Are we ready?
Are you saying you don't have mermaid powers?
What?
Oh, wait. Well, mermaid power?
Okay. My power is I have an extra two fins to make me super agile in the water.
I just wish that's my thing.
I just want to talk to the fish.
Oh, yeah, man.
I'm a toxic mermaid.
I make toxins.
Oh.
That's pretty cool.
Oh, no.
Cleo, the condensation.
Cleo, no.
I know her.
No, no.
The water.
The condensation.
Okay.
We're ready to swim.
Yes.
Three, two, one.
Just to remind you, we can drown.
So let's keep her going.
Let's keep her going.
Little to the right.
Gorgeous, stunning.
Is this a dead end?
Top right, top right, top right.
Oh, sorry, crap.
How do you, how do you go up?
Is it space?
You got to use your mouse.
Aim with your mouse.
Oh, wow.
Okay.
I think we have to go.
We don't go for air.
We should go for air.
Yes, air, air, air.
Oh, no, Amy's stuck.
Amy's stuck.
You stop pulling your, Amy's stuck.
We're going to, you need to come back.
You need to come back.
So Amy can come back up, up.
And then we'll go for air, up.
Yep, yep, yep, up.
And then air, air, right, air, air.
Did I come?
Uh, hope not.
How do you know if we're missing air?
I'm just kidding.
Okay.
Okay, we got air.
We got air.
Right.
Okay, so it's not there.
Okay.
There was another place.
But how do y'all see if we're missing air?
I'm starting to get it.
And they just told us that we can drown.
I believe in the reeflings.
They speak the gospel truth.
The gospel truth.
Do you think we'll hear the drowning sound from Sonic
if we stay under water long enough?
Didi, didi, didi, didi, didi, didi, didi, didi, didi.
Right.
Okay.
Three, two, one, mommy time.
Now we take a left approach to this.
Yeah.
Top left.
Good.
Okay.
Uh-huh.
Is there, uh-huh, uh-huh.
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
Oh yeah.
Very nice.
Tell us how you really feel.
Okay, we're going top right around this corner.
Okay, we're going down.
We're going down for just making, okay,
Randall, Randall, Randall, Randall, and Randall.
Yeah, that's the place.
Yeah, that's okay.
That's okay.
That's the place.
To the right.
We're going back out.
There's a top left here if we want to go.
Yep, yep, yep, yep.
Here?
Is it there?
Uh, there?
Up here.
No, because now we're going back to the start.
No, we're not.
This isn't the start.
We're not?
Uh-huh.
Okay.
This is quite some reason.
Oh, maybe it is the start.
You know what?
You know what, Ms. Ma?
Maybe you are right.
Maybe I'm bad.
I think you're onto it.
Oh, wait.
Is this not the start?
No.
No, it's different.
It's different.
Oh, no.
Oh, we're getting sucked.
How?
Oh.
I think because it was like a hole with the,
with the air.
Oh, okay.
Oh, what is this?
Yeah.
Wait, this is the first official checkpoint.
If you don't use actual checkpoints, that's insane.
Oh, that's messed up.
That is brutal.
Some people like punishing themselves on video games.
I am not that kind of person.
No.
I would not tolerate that from a video game.
Me neither.
I prefer progression and stuff.
Literally.
Just like collabs.
I rather just continue than streaming the same stuff.
Like, I don't know.
Okay.
We've got 10 minutes.
We'll see what we can do in 10 minutes.
Okay?
I mean, look up.
Look up.
We're close, aren't we?
No.
Look at us in the corner.
We're at the first checkpoint out of three.
I am.
We're not.
We ain't making a chief wing.
We ain't making a life.
Like, I need to, I thought we were close.
I thought we were close.
And then I look in the corner and I'm like, oh.
I mean, look down.
We've gotten quite a fort.
Yeah.
It is so big though.
Like, that is so much more.
I miss the car.
Yeah.
I want to go in.
Give us another car sequence.
No.
Okay.
I guess three to one jump because this is a big one.
So we have to do it together.
Yeah.
Come close to us.
Okay.
I'll do this.
Three, two, one, go.
All right.
That was a big one.
We good?
That was very good.
No, ankle's broken.
Okay.
Maybe some, an ankle may have been sprained,
but that's okay.
Spray it at least.
Yeah.
I saw AC hole on it.
Why not?
Oh wait, that's for muscles.
Hold on a minute.
I think Bob, I think you can put a hot thing.
I'm starting my jump.
I thought it looked okay.
No worries.
One of the reasons they are pinging has now gone to 500.
Yeah, hardy hard hard.
Oh, what is the mean?
Oh yeah, the pings to 500.
What is?
Yeah, I'll ping.
Wait, do we have to crouch?
No, no, no.
I think I, I think I get it.
Okay.
It's all strutting.
Yeah.
We have to stand here and kind of keep our balance.
And you have to jump, swaying and grab to the other side.
Oh, that's a, I have to go off on like you drop, like you drop.
Yeah, I think you have to, yeah.
You have to drop and then make it so that,
and we have to pull so that.
Oh, well that could have gone.
Okay.
I got a bit over, over excited there at the concept of jumping off the map.
Um, clearly.
Right.
Wait, so I need to.
Somehow that's just what I'm getting.
Yeah, no, I think you're right.
I think you purposely have to jump off to get on again.
Swing, swing each other.
But all of us can do, yeah.
Okay.
If you all stand behind me and then I'm just going to purposefully swing.
Oh, no, not like that.
I didn't mean to drive.
Wait, whoa.
Wait, did I pull you guys off doing that?
Oh, yeah.
What?
I thought I'm allowed to.
No, I'm too.
No, wait, no, wait.
All right.
Hold on.
I mean, I like being a mermaid, but I'm, I'm, you're such a feather.
What?
It says we didn't.
Surely.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's better.
Right.
Three, two, one.
I knew that.
I was like, no, that, that can't be right because we literally just got a checkpoint.
Yeah.
I wouldn't tolerate that game, Dave.
Someone said.
I know your sly games.
I knew you're sly.
Someone said one on each side.
How do you get the other person to the other side?
I think, I think the front and the back of the chain.
So that would be already in.
Oh, scrawny.
Acty and scrawny.
I'm so confuzzled.
I wish I was in that.
So me and scrawny, we stay on the thing.
Is that it?
Or do you think so?
Okay, wait, wait.
Me and Amy go and we, we stay.
And then you guys on each side jump off.
I think.
I think so.
So can I click on the balance?
Oh, oh, wait.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
No, I get it.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait.
Oh my God.
Okay.
So the front of the line and the back of the line,
they jump off on each side and then we use the chain to slide over.
Yes.
Like the chain, the chain itself.
Like the chain on the log.
Yeah.
So if scrawny and Amy are on the left.
Yes.
Okay.
scrawny jump one side and then acty jump the other.
I'm a bit, I'm a bit the right side here.
I guess you can do it like this where scrawny back up.
Okay.
Ready?
Like this.
Oh, wait, wait.
I go here then.
Yes.
And then I meet your message.
Okay.
All right.
Cool.
Ready?
Three, two, one, go.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, I pulled, I pulled.
No, wait.
You are correct.
No way.
You figured that out.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
What?
Hi, Sycune.
That was so easy.
We did it like fresh, I mean,
fresh try of doing that one try.
That was so easy.
That was very smart.
That was skill.
The end.
What an air thought was amazing.
Right.
I can't believe that.
I'm like, bro, wrap up the stream.
That was a 10 out of 10 moment right at the end there.
Oh, yeah, no, super skill.
Perfect to entertain them.
Well, actually, how did you figure that out?
I was like, because I was like, I was like, okay,
because obviously someone needs to jump
and then I started thinking of different ways.
We could show jump, but then I realized equal weight.
Literally, that was fantastic.
Yeah.
That was so fun to do, too.
I like the slide.
I'm happy to leave it there.
If you guys are happy to leave it there,
because that was amazing.
That was a pretty move.
Yeah, I don't mind.
Yeah, I don't mind either.
Yeah, that was a fun thank you so, so much,
everyone for agreeing to collab.
That was a, I hurt in a hole there.
No, thank you for having us.
I really enjoyed that.
What I'm going to do is,
I'm going to jump out of the voice call
and wrap up my stream.
But of course,
what is that?
It's like just bouncing the tree.
Oh, you want to just bounce?
Okay, that's fine.
Oh, wait, we get more height, the more we jump.
Oh, I guess.
Okay, we're just going to trampoline
to the top at this rate.
But yes, what I'll do is I will leave the call
and I'll wrap up my stream on my end.
But thank you so, so much, Msma.
Thank you so, so much, Acty.
Thank you so, so much.
I'm ever being crazy enough to collab with me.
But it's been, I hurt in a hole there.
I thoroughly enjoyed it.
And I, hopefully, shall be talking to you guys
at later time.
You never know when.
You never know what may be in the works.
Yes, thank you, ma'am.
Sure.
Yes.
But thank you for having us.
Thank you.
Right, I'm three weeks old.
Yes, real three weeks old kitten.
Real untrue.
Okay, right.
Thank you so, so much.
I'm going to jump out of the call.
Thank you.
I'll do the same too.
Bye bye.
Thank you, guys.
It was nice meeting you.
Thank you.
Bye bye.
We're going to see.
We're going to still see all the remodels.
Oh, it's gone.
All right, there we go.
There we go.
Right, we're still in game hold.
They'll be like, uh, I'm going to get this next.
All right, Reblins.
Hi.
Look, I'm not, I actually really enjoy that game.
Sorry.
We might be solo in it.
I'm not even kidding.
We might, oh, why not?
Why am I going to solo?
We might solo that game.
I actually really, really enjoyed that.
Sorry.
I did.
I thought I was a good game.
I like that the game as well actually gave you a chance.
Um, hi John.
He has a fun collab.
I enjoyed it.
Ah, I think we might solo this game.
Normally I get enraged by these types of games.
Like absolutely seething red enraged.
But because the dev team were kind enough to, you know,
not make it impossible, um, I wouldn't mind soloing this.
But the challenge is having more people.
Yeah, but still a challenge for me because I'm dumb.
You did amazing short calls through it.
Bruh.
3, 2, 1, go.
I'm not being funny, but Misma was so on point
when she was like, I'm literally going to be dreaming
about you saying 3, 2, 1, go.
3, 2, 1, go.
Nice.
It's all easy, but thanks for the stream.
No, thank you for watching.
Thank you, it's all easier for the Super Chat.
Thank you the Booty Lord as well for the Super Chat.
And Will Anderson for the membership tier.
That was so fun.
I cannot get over it.
I'm going to be honest.
I picked this game because it was easy to,
I already miss you mommy.
I'm not, I'm still here.
I, so do you have 579 ping?
Bruh, I thought it was ping.
I thought it was ping.
Um, I would have thought the experience
streamer Ace and Maris would be so good at countdown.
I made a countdown joke and I was like,
oh my God, shut up strongy.
Like, I was going to make a countdown like,
oh wait until the teacher about real countdowns.
And I was like, shut the fuck up.
Don't say that.
You're ruining it.
Okay.
That was so fun.
I enjoyed that.
I actually, her actually was having
troubleies through that whole thing.
So I hope she's okay.
You should have said it mommy.
Please.
There's nothing else but dust and not too many countdowns
to stream with it.
We'd have lost our shit if you said it.
Well, I asked the girls.
I was like, is there anything off limits?
And everyone was like, nope.
Don't be one.
And I'm like, well then.
First time I've been given permission to land a bot.
But yes, I am
Tee hee.
So should we see this forbidden recipe
for her noodles?
I feel so bad for Ms.
Ms. Noodles.
We're so cold.
This scantled me.
But that was such a good game.
I picked it because it's like,
obviously the the the game or collab game at the minute.
I thought it was going to be like a bit rubbishy,
a bit nonsense.
That was good.
Shout out to the dev team for being wise enough
to crack the highest unlocked point type thing.
Cause like, oh my god, it looks so sad.
I'm not chained to anyone.
It looks like Play Despacito.
Cause like, sorry, this is such a well done game.
I think this is a really good game.
I honestly wouldn't mind soloing it.
Theater, theater gone.
Cause like, just 10 out of 10 experience.
Dev team's super fair and nice about it.
I just, I know, I know, I know.
Oh, the challenge is like, you know,
actually playing with others.
But like as a standalone game type on its own,
I would never normally play this game type.
But just because of how well they've done it,
you know, I'm, I'mma be a little, a little simp.
Don't mind me.
Right, I said we're just gonna solo the game right now.
Should we?
Wait, should we?
Should I just solo the game right now?
Ms. Ace and Marko have won?
With Ms. Ma?
Oh, careful what you wish for.
I mean, just yeah.
Like, sorry, but this is so fun.
I recommend this game.
I can't remember how much it was, but like,
and yeah, it's fun until you fall.
Well, actually, do we just, I mean,
I'm supposed to be doing a member's ASMR,
but if you guys want to, want to see me play,
I don't mind playing it.
She didn't see you, see me shamelessly.
Oh no, wait, wait, wait, wait, did I miss it?
Oh wait, why am I going so big?
May, may have, wait, why does it?
May have been the brains of the operation,
but I also give good brain, hit me, I'm strong.
No, but I was like,
when you were like, oh, we're ass to ass on the statues,
I'm gonna draw it.
I'm like, don't mind if I do.
Don't mind if I do, because oh.
Oh, shit, I don't know how.
Oh!
Um, illiterately.
I mean, you're gonna yank through the Ace and Marko
stream enemy.
May as well just put this up on the Ace and Marko stream
if you'll enter.
Okay, I nailed that though.
Do a pull for the stream.
Okay, how about that?
I'll do a pull.
Instead of, you know, just, oh my god,
I can't believe that, is it everything I said?
Oh, I'm getting the detail.
Oh my god, it's me!
Wait, wait, start a pull.
What should I do right now?
Question mark.
Okay, there.
I started a pull.
And while you guys vote in the pull,
I'm gonna very quickly do the split.
Wait.
I cannot imagine how hard this gets once you're...
Is that 14th Street station?
Up, down.
Let's be real soon, we need some more.
You know what?
How dare you insult me.
You're surreal for that.
What's this?
Oh, I thought there was gonna be an actual train.
Okay.
Every time you fall, read a marshmallow.
Yeah, I'm true.
Add a third option wherever you want.
I can already see how the pull is gonna go.
Oh wow, it's like, you guys are actually split.
Holy shit.
You demand ASMR once, I'm okay.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe the one that does ASMR is being asked to do ASMR.
Controversial.
Absolutely controversial.
Yeah, I'm true.
In order to go up, we go down.
Very clearly.
Well.
The valley just not ASMR stream or game mapping.
How dare you insult me.
It's entirely true, literally.
Privilege is wrong by doing a real ASMR stream then.
Ah, but then I'm not allowed to talk.
Not even me.
It's gonna be members soon.
Holy crap.
That's actually genuinely the first time I've ever seen you guys split is when it's like this.
I can't believe you want me to do ASMR.
I just, oh, I'm heartbroken truly.
Where the heck am I supposed to put myself in this box right now?
I put myself in the box of shame.
And yapping is what the education stream is.
Just another member's yap afterwards.
Wait, I'm supposed to secretly go this way?
Oh, sorry.
Oh, I'm so excited there.
Okay, right.
I'll wrap it up.
Wrap it up.
Re-saving quit.
Are you sure you want to quit?
Yeah.
Right.
I am going to prepare for a member's ASMR.
That was such a good game.
Please do give me five minutes because I'm going to go for a tinkle and make a cookie scene.
Are you squirming me right now?
Thank you for the super chat, T.I. Crutonson.
ASMR is losing mumma.
There may be angel wings at the bottom.
ASMR for a bit.
Yeah, watch this bit of the game again.
Secretly have the game running in the background.
Right.
If you give me five minutes, I'm going to make a cup of tea.
I'm going to go for a tinkle and then I will set up the member's ASMR.
And then I will do ASMR for a whole five seconds.
I'm so sorry.
That's a little bit too real.
Okay.
Keyboard ASMR and play the game during the ASMR.
My keys are red.
You haven't felt the best part though.
I should, honestly, I should be like, oh, the ASMR member is so exclusive, so good.
For those of you who aren't a member, please don't actually worry about the member's content.
The reason I say that is because there's a running gag.
I always plan, I have members ASMR and within maybe 10 minutes,
I give up on actually doing the ASMR because I'm just so excited to talk.
Um, which is why we yap.
That's why the ASMR gets me done because I always don't.
The, the public ASMR streams are about 10 times more professional than any membership stream
I've ever done.
Okay.
So don't, if you're like, oh, I feel, I feel, I suck that I'm missing out.
You're not missing out.
I am being outrageous.
Outrageous stuff.
10 minutes mean generous.
It's more like a minute, real and true.
Um, yes, you're doing a good job with the kiss and ASMR.
Yes, I, it's, we all mean it on it.
Right.
Give me the ability to redirect into Shibi if she's streaming, but I don't know if she's
streaming, but I hope that she is streaming so I can redirect and give me one more chance.
Doesn't look like she's streaming.
I enjoy your voice.
I can listen to it for days.
Wait, why is the thumbnail vermin tamed?
What?
The thumbnail says vermin tamed too for me.
YouTube, please wake up and spell the daisies.
What's going on with these thumbnails?
I don't know why it's like having such a meep.
An absolute mental, mental, ex-oriental like thing going on because it's not vermin tamed.
So who is next?
It would be Azura is online at 11.
What? You're going to redirect into a stream that's five hours away?
Yes.
What are you going to do about it?
Far?
Are you scared that you might enjoy the stream in five hours time?
Exactly.
Yeah, that's right.
Don't be s-
That's right.
Yeah.
You haven't had the thumbnail change for the last two streams?
A thumbnail show with the trutist tumor truly once.
Well, we're doing vermin tamed stream snipe.
Oh wait, I can show you my schedule.
Wait, did I even show you my schedule?
Now, hold on a minute.
Let me show you my schedule.
Don't you go anywhere just yet.
I'm not done with you.
This is my-
Nope, it's not my schedule.
Scheisse.
It's not made.
Okay, well, right.
Here's verbally what my schedule is.
Not on the correct day.
Okay.
College of Black Ops one campaign.
Vermintide two with you, not on a weekend for the stream snipe.
This is for people who work on the weekends.
Doodling my gen mates is coming up.
Golfic collab with my gen mates is coming up.
Hypnosis ASMR to forget your name.
A member's valetral stream.
A member's script writing stream.
We're watching the Kingsman, the Secret Service.
We are playing and finishing Peggle.
And we are also 100% Sonic Heroes.
And we are also playing Tavern Master, a game about owning a tavern.
I thought it was cute.
Reminded me of kind of the Hobbit vibe.
So we're playing that, get right.
A W week.
But yes, I'm writing the Hypnosis to forget your name script.
I'll be very interested.
It's going to be a live stream.
My only note about next week's schedule is the ASMR stream.
Is that Icey's time slot?
Because I'm going to redirect into Icey.
That was my PC.
It wasn't your PC.
That was mine.
Virus and threat protection.
Windows didn't detect anything.
We're getting Peggle this week.
Oh, you're getting Peggle so hard in all of that.
Windows said it was me.
It was me.
Okay, don't panic.
College of Black Ops one, Vermintide two, Doodling gen mates.
Hypnosis ASMR.
Look at you.
You take that fast as anything.
Yes, we're going to finish Peggle campaign mode.
We're going to finish Sonic Heroes.
We're kind of finishing up streams that we started.
College of Black Ops campaign, I think is six hours together.
Golfic collab with my gen mates is two hours or less.
Maybe an hour and a half.
It may be a bit shorter.
Just because it's on Azure's doughnathon.
Obviously, the focus is on Azure, not us.
We will be redirecting into Azure, all that jazz on her doughnathon.
The Black Ops are going to bring back lobby flashbacks and all of us.
At some point, I can see you're doing Cod Zombies.
Oh no, I'm terrified of Cod Zombies.
I can't do it on my own.
I'm too scared.
Are you going to play Super Hard mode in Sonic Heroes?
Wait, what?
I thought 100% was finishing Team Chaos, Team Rose.
I don't know that.
Have you decided the enemy?
It's Vivi Eyeball, something.
Good luck.
I don't know the name of it.
Remember that time I had a laugh and fit over a freaking happy sugar life?
Hold on.
Let me link that.
You'll hear me twice.
Remember that time I had a laugh and fit?
Are you ready?
Oh, another score.
The fucking tear drop.
I didn't expect the physics.
So yeah, if you didn't watch the happy sugar life, watch along.
I have time stamped if you want to watch it along with me and be shocked at the anime series.
I time stamped the laugh and then I ended up having a laughing fit because I didn't expect.
So a tear randomly drops on her face.
And you know, maybe in me.
Oh, Azura is cancelling today's stream.
So we're going to redirect him to Mercy instead.
Hold on.
Let me type in Chiki Mercy Modist.
Um...
Mercy, Mercy, Mercy.
Mercy, Mercy.
Today she's streaming.
Well, I'm going to redirect you into stream that seven hours away.
Yes, I am.
What are you going to do?
Start?
Nothing.
You're not going to do a thing.
I'm sure you've been forced to enjoy it.
Okay.
I don't care what you say.
Should it?
Should it be?
Strony started to wind down and I said something and I started off again.
Oh, it was that Harry Potter receipt one.
Man, I was pottering my puppy.
I couldn't catch the HSL VOD this morning like I wanted.
When you watch it, just be warned.
Episode five, I have a laughing fit.
So if you want to watch it with me, I have time stamped it.
If you go into the VOD, it's all time stamped.
So if you're wanting to put something on in the background
and watch an Annie Moose with me, you're more than welcome to.
Obviously, I yapped for like 20 minutes as always.
You're sensei humorous, Kate.
Bruh.
Ray Jimmy.
I don't think Emmy is up today.
I know there most likely is a stream displayed on Emmys,
but I don't think it's happening.
If it is, I apologize.
But I am under the impression that our beloved little sister
needs some time.
So please do not be upset if she does not stream
and delete it for a later date.
Yes.
Unless she has given an indication on Twitter that she's doing something.
Ah, did she say?
I didn't realize she said.
Did she say on her alternative Twitter?
Ah, she did.
Fuck, yeah.
She said it 30 minutes ago.
Emmy's pet passed away and she doesn't feel very good.
She has been given full permission to not, you know,
you don't need fucking permission from us to not stream or anything like that.
That's absolutely fuck all to do with us.
Yes.
So we will redirect into Mercy.
It's seven hours away.
I know it's quite the time away, but it is what it is.
But yes, Emmy has absolutely no, as with anyone, a veiler.
And she has no obligation to stream.
None of that fucking.
No one gives a shit.
No one gives a shit about what a little piece of paper contracts is.
She can take all the time she needs.
And that is that.
If you want to leave some nice messages,
why the fuck is my VTuber model so cool?
If you want to leave some nice messages in her marshmallow,
you can grab the link via her descriptions on any video or anything like that.
Even if it's just a love heart, something nice.
You most certainly can.
But yes, one of her pets passed away.
So she is not going to stream for a little while.
I don't think.
We're just about, obviously, we're fucking fine.
I haven't seen anything.
Right, I'm going to redirect into Mercy.
Give me five minutes.
I will make a cup of honey tea and then swap around my microphones.
So, yes.
Sorry to end that on such a sad note.
But yeah, I just, I don't want anyone thinking, you know, oh my god.
I mean, it feels forced to stream.
Nope, no, that shit is all the time she needs.
We ain't like that.
We don't do that shit here.
We do not give two fucking shits about fucking the week like that.
I assure you.
Right, I do apologize for ending on such a sad note.
I did find out yesterday and yes.
Okay.
Thank you for the good stream.
Appreciate it.
As always, I'm very thankful towards Misma,
very thankful towards Aimee,
and very thankful towards Acty for collabing and playing with me.
I was very nice to them because I set that collab up.
And we had funsies because I'm always like, oh no, what happened?
But yes, it was very nice.
Right, I am going to go and get ready and make a cup of tea.
Okay.
Thank you so, so much.
I will see you shortly in the member stream.
If not, I will see you tomorrow for Handcam Popping Cooking.
Yes, I'm putting my fake nails on.
You want to know why?
Because the glue is still stuck on top of my nails.
I can't get it off.
Okay.
Tomorrow is Handcam Popping Cooking
and also Member Stream Discussion Donut on the wards.
But if there's any leaks, I will never ever talk about that shit again.
Because that's not the deal.
Cooking was trying to be eating goods.
Ask the tone, Momay.
I'm no.
Ask the tones the reason why I had like nae freaking nails.
The stride, my nails.
Mummy forever sticky, if you'll enter.
The opera singer got it for a sec.
We can keep it a secret, Momay.
Ah, you better.
Or else you're all getting a spanking.
You're all getting lined up and spanked.
Right.
I am going to go make a honey tea.
I'll be back in five minutes.
Okay.
I will swap around to the 3DO.
This cheeky microphone.
I give you kisses.
I give you four kisses because there was four of us in this collab.
One, two, three, four.
Oh, I recorded the kiss and collab we wrote together, by the way.
Oh no, it's not collab.
Well, it was a collab between us coming up with it.
So, you know what?
Okay.
I'll see you tomorrow, or I'll see you in five minutes, by the way.
Thank you so so much.
Please enjoy being redirected into a stream that's seven hours away.
Bye.